les terrains qui est un sous sol
calcaire et au vent léger à quelques 100
mètres d'altitude sur ce plateau à
d'avron les conditions semble-t-il et à
la maturation des raisins et donc à
l'obtention d'un vin de grande qualité
on plante du chardonnay du chemin en
blanc et en plantes du merlot et du
pinot noir en rouge
donc c'est des choix de ces pages qu'on
a fait en fonction des potentiels de
maturité qui a ici en fonction du climat
fonction des sols aussi on a fait des
choix de deux cépages pour certains qui
sont habituellement cultiver un peu plus
au sud
et on souhaite faire un pari d'avenir en
les amenant un peu plus au nord pour les
amener en limite de maturité âgés de 27
à 31 ans julien bru style c'est julien
bengué et adrien pélissier sont les
trois fondateurs de la winery parisienne
ce sont eux qui ont eu l'idée
d'installer dans les yvelines le premier
vignoble professionnels d'ile-de-france
un vignoble de 16 mille pieds l'objectif
commercial c2c de pouvoir faire
découvrir localement ses 20 ans les
rendre abordable au plus grand nombre
donc pour la distribuer aux filières
courtes et en circuit court pour que les
yvelinois puissent profiter du fruit de
leur terroir le département soutient
l'initiative pour son président
l'objectif est aussi de renforcer le
caractère rural des yvelines je ne
pensais pas qu'on pouvait très
honnêtement faire du vin à des fins
commerciales dans le département des
yvelines et le réchauffement climatique
l'imagination de ces jeunes gens
maintenant convaincus et donc oui on
fait le pari avec eux et je suis
convaincu que ce sera un pari gagnant
les premières vendanges sont attendus
pour 2020 si l'essai est concluant
l'exploitation pourrait atteindre les 26
hectares